The Joe Rogan Experience I know you
exercise a lot you used to be German I
know I I know you used to Be Giants I
was 40 pounds bigger than I am oh my God
literally what what made you get so
jacked I got the flu and then
you got me jacked yeah um I just uh well
I'll tell you what I did but it was when
I got that permanent gig I had nothing
to do all day in Vegas literally just
started getting so I started just going
to the gym every day like I'd go three
hours a day literally three hours of
lifting yeah well this is again 15 years
ago right and I was I I just was huge
and one day I went to my warehouse to do
something it was a picture of something
and I was like what the [ __ ] like I'm
like I was like
190. I'm like 140. this is my this is my
original fighting right now I'm at 140
is my is my uh that's what you feel yeah
this is where I grew up born and raised
135 140 my whole life and then I went to
like 185 people like what did you have a
lot of joint pain all the time yeah
everything I was always injured I always
always hurt yeah didn't look good on
stage it was just it was weird as like
you know people are like what the [ __ ]
happened to Karen Tom they've always
said that but that is a thing though
when you get really jacked on stage it
becomes a distraction it did yeah it did
yeah Gene Simmons of all people came
says uh does being so muscular and take
away from the uh the uh that's the worst
thing ever
all said Gene Sims became like an
Englishman from the 80s
so I got Gene really good one time so
this is great so he comes back to him
the show comes backstage and he said he
says to me
um what do you do
to make money besides
this and I said what the [ __ ] is done
nothing he said you don't have any of
the things that give you money I said I
don't I don't know I do comedy six
nights a week but you don't have another
investment of some sort yes it's trying
to offer you some prostitution well no
yeah
no you were really weird and uh Gene
listen I'm seeing somebody okay but um
uh let me try on your platforms no so I
so I uh just let me slipping them I want
teeth on my shoes but he says to me and
this is great because I'm being I'm
being like really serious with him right
so I said uh well I said no but I I uh I
did one thing a long time ago I I wrote
a jingle
um
like what's the jingle and I said it's
by Menon and he says
I'm not following you I say remember the
commercial by Menon and he goes
that was you and I said yeah he says get
the [ __ ] I said no I said my friend
hasn't had an organ in my garage he had
left there and we were out [ __ ]
around and this that by Menon thing we
had a campaign that said come up with a
jingle
so we did we came up with it just wasn't
even funny which is by men and and we
sent it to the men and whatever the was
it under whatever yep and uh he says
wait a second so that you did that's
you're making this up I said no he said
how much did they pay for that I said
I'm still I still get money for it I
said it was amazing but it was just kind
of a fluke I said we tried to come up
with other things
and he's looking at me like that is just
um remarkable and I said yes
and then he said I said uh and see
that's great and I said anything else I
said well I came up with now with Retson
and he says what are you talking about I
said with Retson remember the certs and
he goes you're [ __ ] me I said yes he
goes but the men and thing I said no
it's all [ __ ] he lost his he lost
his [ __ ] he's like God damn it I sat
there for 20 minutes I believe in he
came up with by Menon and Retson I said
no I never but I got him good on his
show because I did I did the when he had
it at his house that uh oh the reality
show yeah yeah so Family Jewels first
met him I I go Family Jewels and I go
and uh he says my impression uh you want
to see my uh my warehouse and I said
sure So it takes me to this huge wing of
his house I mean literally it's probably
the size
Walmart it's full he says to me I've got
I've got everything asked I said well of
course you have a kiss condom I mean he
goes oh yeah yeah yeah because coffin's
waving we've kissed everything you know
and I said uh I said uh and we're on
we're live or they're filming me with
him and I said uh good towards the end I
said he said well thank you for dropping
by and I said I said I don't want to
this is going to come across completely
[ __ ]
wrong I says don't take this the wrong
way and he says what I said you're going
to take this the wrong way he says what
I said
I've never heard of this your band you
must I said you must have done well but
I've never heard of kiss and he says
it's like a really weird because you've
never heard a kiss I said no I see I
knew you'd take it the wrong way I said
I just I I mean look at all this holy
[ __ ] I've never heard are you guys how
long have you guys been a band and he
looked at me like
he's gonna [ __ ] kill me and I said I
said I know like Hanson I know Hanson
this is when they were hitting it big
you know I said I know Hanson right and
he goes you [ __ ] me I said no I don't
I never heard of Kiss
and that's fine I said I'm [ __ ] with
you come on and then I got him again
and he was serious he like he really
believed you oh yeah no